Hello
Bitches,
I'm,
I can,
I just get incredibly man.
I'm fucking again.
I waiting a good day.
First of all,
I can't find it.
Shoot when I don't have my own ice
skates.
So I have to rent.
Ice Skates is for the same reason why I
couldn't for years.
I can rent.
Those are fucking shitty.
Well it's not even just that my feet are
too wide.
So if I had a regular size 11,
my feet,
I have someone in my background fucked a
monkey when it was big fucking big foot
one time ago.
Like when you shouldn't be able to fuck
monkeys anymore.
Someone just went back in for one more
shot,
fucked a monkey.
Guaranteed.
It was like the last,
like last call evolution last car and
one of my ancestors just snuck back in
and got one more nut off.
Um,
but my feet are just too wide so I get
in those things.
I'm just in agony and I just never
learned how.
And I'm not gonna I'm not interesting
enough for me to go out and buy ice
skates.
Know it felt like this is it.
It's just something I have to conquer.
Then I would have to learn how to ice
skate.
It was much more exciting as a youth.
Yeah,
fucking roller.
Not Roller blading.
Fucking ice skating to green day shit
like that.
You know what I mean?
That's right.
They play loud music and you spin around
the ice.
See,
I guess hockey would be the reason to do
it.
Like if you wanted to learn how to play
hockey,
you pretend you're.
You're doing hockey moves and like
you're on the ice.
Snowing.
When you stop and you throw the snow of
people know the right.
That's a cool move.
Yeah,
exactly.
So you were the hockey skates.
You definitely don't wear the figure
skating ones.
No chance.
No,
you don't.
What's the difference?
Well,
they had the spikes in the front,
so you could do the triple toe Lutz.
You don't want anybody to know what you
don't want anybody seeing your spikes.
Definitely.
Well,
you're going to.
When you go straight you have to lift it
a little bit and you're going to fall on
your face.
The hockey is a little curvature,
like a running shoe.
It just allows you to maneuver,
to dice so it allows you to maneuver
better,
but it doesn't allow you to do tricks.
Can't do.
You can't do a stop.
And then triple toe alerts or Lego Scott
Hamilton flip.
So are they doing flips and when they do
those spins on the ice they do on them
with like special skates?
Is that what the deal is?
Sure.
Brian Channel
and I've noticed with archery my ego,
even when I will have me shoot the Arrow
and the exact same way,
even though I'm still off the fucking
target,
you know,
I,
you say no,
no,
you were right or wrong.
That's how the brain works.
Like it felt right.
Just keep doing it.
So,
so,
so you've got to.
Even though the feedback from the
universe like,
nope,
wrong,
don't take that approach to bud fucking
ever hurt somebody or hurt somebody.
Stops screaming.
I'm doing it right.
Yeah.
Right,
exactly.
But think of it man.
So I certainly am in my life,
have erred by choosing my instinct over
the feedback I'm getting from the
universe.
Well,
this is like that book that you
introduced me to,
which I war of art.
Now,
the book of five rings.
Oh,
the real one.
And the one that talks about how uh,
you should just learn anything like,
get good at anything.
It doesn't matter what the thing is that
you're getting good at it because if you
understand how to get good at this one
thing,
you can extrapolate from that how to get
good at almost anything.
There's these recurring patterns that
happen.
And so with archery it's really cool
because you have to find these.
You have to keep all these variables the
same no matter what your environment,
if you can learn to keep these variables
the same.
If you're on a hill,
the distance in wind,
whatever.
If you can learn how to hold these
variables the same,
which is the anchor point,
the way your arm holds the bow,
the way you pull the Arrow back,
the way you release the air,
there's all these pieces in there.
And if you can keep all of those the
same or close to the same with
adjustments based on whatever your
target app is to be,
then you're going to improve in your
accurate accuracy.
If you keep changing your variable,
if you keep moving your arm up or down
or like releasing in a different way or
whatever.
If any of these things are always
changing,
you won't be as accurate over time.
So from that you can grab that and look
at your life and realize like,
Oh shit man,
my wife,
I've just been readjusting all these
stupid variables over and over and over
again without just for at least a month
attempting some rhythmic pattern.
Some similar thing,
you know.
And when you start doing that,
it's really interesting because you
begin to improve in a lot of,
in everything in general.
I mean there's,
there's arguments to anthropology that
actually they were lots of societies
that had a lot more leisure time than we
do,
you know,
hunting,
gathering societies and spending four to
five hours a day,
quote unquote working hunting,
gathering and had lots of time for
ceremonies and all kinds of other
things.
It depends on where you are in the world
and how harsh the conditions were,
but,
but the,
you know,
sort of the original leisure society
May,
it may have predated,
predated agriculture,
something they had no iphones and maybe
that was a blessing,
who knows,
but for five hours of hunting and
gathering is exhausting,
you know,
and you really don't have enough time to
develop a car.
No,
no cars.
Yeah.
After you figured that out,
after you've done your hunting and
gathering,
then it's about cooking and.
But also there's no days off because you
don't have any refrigeration,
right?
Depending on,
depending on your climate.
And I mean they could,
they could try things and do certain
things,
but clearly,
clearly not a,
not a frigidaire around the corner.
Oh,
but you know what you're talking about
about whether it's cities or just modern
society,
that
high tech,
high speed world that most of us live
in,
where many of us don't feel like we have
much free time and we're running around
and doing all these things in cities.
Usually
when I talk to people who become hunters
as adults,
by and large,
that's part of why they did it.
They wanted to reconnect.
Yeah.
You know,
it's part of why they garden is part of
why they raise chickens.
It's part of why they do all sorts of
other things that you understand and
value to.
They want to get back in touch with
those.
Not only the hands on skills,
but just the world they inhabit.
You know,
beyond the domesticated concretized
city.
Concretize
the pavement,
you know,
beyond the pavement into nature and
whether it's a little garden patch in
your backyard or you hunting around the
Missouri breaks,
you know,
there's a sense of wanting to reconnect
so that all these practices,
hunting,
gardening,
raising chickens in part are like an
antidote
to modern life.
So do you want to.
You want me to tell you a bit about the
evolutionary roots of religion,
how,
how you would study religion as an
evolutionist.
Okay.
You Ready?
Yeah.
So one argument is based on.
It's an adaptive argument,
right?
So the idea is if religion exists,
does it confer an adaptive advantage to
people?
And so there was some work done by a
good friend of mine,
David Sloan Wilson and evolutionary
biologist where he argues using the
groups selectionists argument that that
groups that are religious out survive
groups that are not by virtue of them
being more communal,
more cohesive,
more abandoned.
So that argument is an adaptive argument
for why religion exists.
There is another argument by other
evolutionists that is based on an
exaltation arguing.
Have you ever heard that term?
Exactly.
What does that mean?
So that's a byproduct of evolution.
In other words,
it's something that evolved not because
itself,
it confers an adaptive advantage,
but rather it's piggybacking.
So for example,
the fact that your skeletal system is
the color that it is,
that itself is not adaptive.
It is a byproduct of other evolutionary
processes.
So from that perspective,
religion piggybacks on computational
systems in our brains that evolved for
other things.
You follow me,
for example,
coalitional thinking,
the idea of viewing the world as US
versus them,
blue team versus team.
That is an innate part of our psychology
now.
Now religion piggybacks on that,
right?
It takes that computational system that
already exists in us and it,
it puts it on steroids,
right?
So you think about the Abrahamic
religions,
right?
Every one of them has us versus them.
They are the Jews,
the gentiles,
the believers,
the preferred,
right?
And so at agency detection detecting
agency and things is something that is
innate to us.
Religion plays on that.
The agent becomes God,
and so that's an argument that was
proposed by Pascal where he's basically
saying that religion not specifically
evolve because itself,
it is adaptive,
but it piggybacks on other things that
have evolved.
And then a third way to study a religion
is to just do a content analysis of the
the,
the narratives within religions.
So there's a great study done by a
Darwinian historian where she looked at
in the old testament how many women are
ascribed to a different male and the in
the Old Testament as a function of a
status.
So the higher the status of the male,
the more sexual partners you had,
which is exactly what you would predict
from an evolutionary perspective.
High status to men confers reproductive
success.
So there are different ways that
evolution is.
And there are several other ways that
can study religion from an evolutionary
perspective.